c'est la 29e édition du trophée sport
passion comme chaque année une
soixantaine de sportifs de haut niveau
se réunissent ici pour se défier
s'affronter au golf de feucherolles je
suis en présence de la fondatrice régime
grandeur fini bonjour bonjour alors
comment se passe cette édition et bien
déjà ils sont nombreux donc ce matin on
a les 190 personnes d'inscrites entre
les sportifs de haut niveau nos
partenaires leurs invités et quelques
journalistes présents qui joue la
compétition également on est très
content parce qu'avec les deux dernières
années ça a été quand même assez
compliqué puisque l'art entre les deux
éditions il s'est passé six mois
seulement avec les reports que l'on a
eues en 2021 on est au golf de
feucherolles 27 éditions sur 29 ici
c'est symbolique pour vous
le golf est parti en fait l'histoire du
trophée sport passion les les deux
éditions qu'on n'a pas fait ici c'était
pour des pour des raisons techniques on
va dire donc au niveau du restaurant ici
et les travaux qui étaient en cours donc
c'était plus compliqué une année où on
s'était dit on va aller à saint nom la
bretèche pour avoir deux parcours parce
qu'on a beaucoup de demandes et au final
tout le monde voulait revenir à
feucherolles donc voilà le trophée c'est
feugerolles qui sont les têtes d'affiché
un peu cette année il ya pas mal de
sportifs et les maquis sont présents et
on va avoir du thé cuando présent de la
boxe donc on à astrid et priscilla et
nieto qui sont là on a aussi une
championne du monde toutes récentes de
longboard donc il ya plein de jeunes
nouveau dans des sports qui ont un peu
émergé qui sont présents et j'en suis
ravi parce que le l'esprit du trophée
sport passion c'est ça c'est de réunir
sur une même journée des sports très
médiatisées comme le football
le handball le rugby et des sports un
petit peu moins médiatisé avec des
sportifs en activité dont que les gens
connaissent ou moins qui sont moins
disponibles et faire un petit peu ce
mélange qui va faire que la journée à la
fin en soirée elle est explosive écoutez
nous on va aller tout de suite à la
rencontre des sportifs merci beaucoup
régine gandolfi ni d'avoir été avec nous
en scramble donc on est à deux ans prend
la meilleure balle donc j'ai un super
footballeur qui a acquis un super joueur
d'une oeuvre donc ça m'aide c'est un peu
une habitude c'est pas la première fois
que je vais faire cette répétition pour
trophée sport passion des anciens
footballeurs et bien le gall veulent
donc voilà comme on est encore dans la
région on en profite pour venir partager
entre footballeurs mais aussi avec
d'autres sportifs
comme nous le disions énormément de
sportifs de haut niveau ici dont
certains qui viennent depuis longtemps
philippe candeloro bonjour bonjour donc
vous vous êtes un peu une icône ici un
parent l'année dernière mais toujours
présent cette année comment ça se passe
je partie du parcours moi je suis un
arbre ici j'ai dû faire 25 éditions 27
éditions ici à feucherolles c'est cette
année la 29e édition donc ouais si on
peut ne pas rater une édition du sport
passion je pense que c'est important
puisqu'on passe tous une très très belle
journée à chaque fois vous attend pour
la trentième édition aussi l'année
prochaine à bas la 30e fera pas la rater
j'ai le temps défini je pense qu'elles
ont envie de faire une très très belle
soirée pour la trentième édition parce
que voilà trente ans c'est quand même
beau c'est une belle c'est une belle
réussite ce trophée et on est contents
d'y participer chaque année et pour
conclure forcément on se retrouve avec
le parrain de cette édition bertrand
amoussou bonjour bonjour alors quand ça
s'est passé ce parcours vous venez de
terminer à l'instant oui alors ça s'est
passé on joue pas beaucoup heureusement
qui origine pour ne faire jouer au golf
une fois par an mais non lance-t-il
magnifique je sais pas comment est fait
mais à chaque fois il fait beau donc là
je pense qu'elle a une connexion directe
à le 06 de 2 à aulas il se passe un truc
mais ne l'en c'est génial et eric une
équipe formidable comme chaque année
magnifique je crois qu'il nous reste
plus qu'une chose à dire pour conclure
c'est qu'on se retrouve l'année
prochaine pour les 30 ans la 30e édition
du trophée sport passion
[Musique]